[MUSIC PLAYING]
Probably after San
Xavier Mission,
Old Main is the most important
building in Southern Arizona.
I don't think you'd get a
lot of arguments about that.
The importance of it relative
to the University of Arizona,
and the importance of
the University of Arizona
in this community.
And so when you get to work
on that, that's spectacular.
When you get to
work on a building
that is not just
important, but as we've
worked on the building,
we've come to understand what
a great building it is.
What a great building
it is for this climate,
for the U of A campus,
for this community.
And to get to follow in the
footsteps of the architect
and builder who did that project
in 1887 to 1891 is privilege.
How often do you get to do that?
The way we practice
architecture is very much
tied to this place,
a sense of place,
and Tucson is a very
demanding climate.
And it's also a location with
a big, long cultural history.
And the buildings
that we try to do,
that are contemporary
buildings, all
need to respond to the
desert environment,
and all need to be responsive
to the culture of this place.
And that's what I mean
by sense of place.
And people use it
in terms of art.
People use it in terms of music.
It's the connection between
an art form or a design,
and the location in
which it's placed.
[BANGING]
So when we first
started the project,
there was this rumor
floating around.
And the rumor
floating around was
that the floor between the
upper level and the lower level
was filled with dirt.
And we didn't know if
that was true or not.
It was a pretty strong
rumor and, sure enough,
the entire floor, about
12,000 square feet
of floor between the
first and second,
has about 2 and
1/2 inches of dirt
covering the entire
space between the floor
and the ceiling.
And the reason they did that
was for sound attenuation,
that you had a wooden floor
with a wooden structure sitting
over classrooms over classrooms.
And people were worried that
as people walked on the floor,
that the sound would
reverberate down.
And a good way to deaden sound
is with a massive material,
a heavy material, and so
dirt was the perfect material
to use.
So when you opened up the floor,
you were looking at all dirt,
and we were looking at the floor
after they took the dirt out,
and we noticed that there
were pieces, every once
in awhile, that were painted.
And we couldn't
figure out what that
was until we took all those
out and put them together
in a puzzle, and
it turned out it
was the original construction
sign with the name
of the contractor on it.
And they just cut that
up in little pieces
and used that for the shelving.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What the architect,
James Creighton, did
is he understood
that over the years
this building was going
to grow and change.
The demands on it were
going to change over time.
And so what he built was
a very simple structure,
in which it consists
of a cruciform,
and then he built four
quadrants, four big rooms.
And then he built two wings,
north and south, which
were all originally empty.
And he designed that so that all
of the people at the University
of Arizona that followed
could modify those spaces
as they needed them
over hundreds of years.
And so our intent is to
take this historic shell
and make it back the way it
was when it was first built,
and then go in and fill in that
shell with all brand new uses,
with new technology, and new
offices, and new furniture,
and be able to tell
the difference.
So when you walk
into Old Main, you
will understand that you're
looking at a modern interior
in a historic building.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm going to really
honored to be
part of this next iteration--
this next group of users
that try to respect
that original building.
We had a really nice
visit with President Hart.
And we were standing
in this big open space,
and we were talking
about the glass walls
and the contemporary materials.
And I just turned
to her, and I said
you know this gives me a
little bit of goosebumps,
because this is exactly what
James Creighton intended
us to do when he finished
the building in 1891.
He knew that 122
years later, folks
would be in here doing
exactly what we're doing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]